denis coderre est avec nous bonsoir
monsieur monsieur roy mes hommages va
bien oui lanières fois qu'on s'est vus
sur les épaules ça va mieux
la dernière entrevue vous dit pas tout
sourit je vous dit il n'y avait pas deux
fois testé en campagne électorale
vous voulez revenir mais je connais bien
coûter 1
c'est un put dans le même sens que le
livre moi je trouve que montréal a perdu
beaucoup de sa superbe
je pense qu'on a un leadership à assumer
au niveau de la métropole lieu le
quartier tout seul et ça c'est important
je pense qu'avec la pandémie surtout la
sortie de la pandémie
on va avoir besoin injustement de
d'assumer pleinement ce rôle
alors de temps au niveau du
développement économique développement
social de ramener cette notion de
contrepoids je dirai pas ce que vous
souvenez à l'époque on avait quand même
sa magnifique l'autonomie municipale y
avait les régissent les autres
municipalités on avait le statut de
métropole
j'ai senti qu'on l'a pas utilisé à
pleine capacité d'ailleurs vous avez vu
la ministre sous l'eau la semaine
dernière là on voit plus le cas il ya
des tiraillements mais ce que le
portable ne prend pas si sa place dans
l'échiquier politique du québec
je parle de l'administration parce que
je veux vous parler des individus mais
moi ce que j'aime c'est ce qui me désole
ce qui me désole ne se revoient ce que
j'ai l'impression qu'on apprend à
montréal pour tous les montréalais
j'ai l'impression que c'est toujours le
crois ou meurs que le vivre ensemble on
est on n'est pas dedans que on est en
train de mettre se braquer avec les
moyens de transport que c'est le croit
ou marseille c'est tout ou rien puis je
pense que montréal est tellement une
ville exceptionnelle avec le fait que ça
se vide au centre-ville la réalité des
commerçants la réalité de création de
richesse et de la distribuer je pense
que on a besoin au moins de présenter
une alternative
qu'est-ce que vous avez changé dans
votre façon d'être qui va vous permettre
de dire aux montréalais j'échange il ya
des leçons que j'ai appris
concrètement qu'est ce que c'est la
différence du nouveau coderre avec
l'ancien canal je pense qu'on grandit de
nos
de nos échecs je pense qu'on grandit de
nos événements des crises que l'on peut
vie c'est quand le livre que j'écris
retrouver montréal c'est avant tout ma
façon de me retrouver aussi et j'avais
des problèmes personnels
g j'ai pensé au pire et puis j'ai régir
équilibrer ma vie la confiance ça se
mérite
on a toujours travaillé c'est sûr que je
suis humain je peux avoir fait des arums
en faire encore mais cette expérience
cette capacité de se relever cette
résilience à mon avis fait en sorte que
je pourrai démontrer la population que
là dessus je me suis transformé mais
aussi la question d' équipe il ya des
gens qui avaient l'impression que je
tends radiant des gens qui disaient que
j'étais un one man show c'est sûr puis
un peu quand on parle par exemple aux
médias moi je te tout mais les membres
du comité exécutif pourrait faire les
entrevues
on avait des fois l'impression qu' il y
en avait que pour le maire mais ce qui
est clair c'est que deux des réalités
auxquelles j'étais conforte et je pense
qu'il faut changer mais je comptais vous
ne parliez de c'est parce que il ya des
gens qui vous ont dit depuis hier
pendant attendre tout à l'heure à 10 ans
sur dans une seconde c'est très court
mais jacky ont déjà choisi les missions
les plus populaires pour briller il n'y
a pas choisi de faire une conférence de
presse avec des collègues des nouveaux
collègues votre bras droit ou votre bras
droits féminins ou masculins
il a choisi de faire encore un one man
show et de nous prendre pour acquis
votre ami pas un adversaire politique
il y annonce qui se présente avec un
centre montréal
plusieurs de mes collègues de beaucourt
ans c'est un travail d'équipé
ça c'est des choses qui se planifie
peut-être plus à la vente
on prend le temps de s'asseoir avec les
gens pour échanger aussi donc cette
partie là je pense qu'il aura la halle
travailler à vous dit vous avez à
travailler votre esprit desquels on a
plus l'impression hier soir aujourd'hui
qu'il y avait une équipe avec vous on va
faire deux choses la première c'est qui
est un auteur présente un lit
j'ai mis quatre ans de ma vie là dessus
il ya un travail d'équipé qui a été fait
et puis je pense que c'est important de
pouvoir le présenter puis je finance
voté juste avec vous ce soir à faire des
missions jamais vu sa politique
quelqu'un qui se lancent qui se relance
dans votre camp et qui ne l'annoncent
pas d'abord en conférence de presse
moi j'ai jamais vu ça j'ai beau reculé
mais depuis je t'ai tout petit je n'ai
jamais vu ça on peut faire autrement je
soupçonne important
moi moi aujourd'hui j'offre une vision
et je veux aller aux halles encore à la
rencontre des montréalais
je prends personne par surprise plus
jeunes une vision maintenant annie gelé
pour rencontrer j'ai parlé à beaucoup de
gens je ne sais pas quand j'arrive comme
un cheveux saas ou alors il faut avoir
un caucus demain il ya beaucoup de gens
qui m'ont appelé c'est pas aux cadets
qui veut y aller aussi les beaucoup de
gens dans la rue il ya des gens de tous
les niveaux qui me parlent et grâce à
montréal aussi mais je connais dans
votre partie vous dites il y en a un
certain nombre qui était au courant non
mais je parlais avec je parle avec
lionel perret je parlais avec certaines
personnes mais faut respecter les choses
de dieu des membres du caucus des élus
alors vivons faire ils vont faire leur
rencontre
mais voilà ce qui est important c'est
que je vais aussi des obligations
professionnelles ne peut pas arriver
comme ça dit bon ben je me présente le
caureq je pourrais pas faire de
politique pendant ce temps alors j'avais
une réflexion profonde à faire j'ai
projet propose une vision parce que je
voulais pas que les gens le bus par
suprise bon y'a rien à nous offrir
on a en a un
un ouvrage qui va permettre des débats
puis on voit grandir ensemble
il ya des gens qui spéculaient à votre
antenne que j'allais partir mon propre
parti
je n'ai même pas lu le commencer par
savoir ce que je voulais faire et dans
un deuxième temps dit que je peux pas
laisser tomber des anciens collègues
parce que moi j'ai eu à me prends à me
refaire une santé
et puis j'ai j'ai retrouvé ce goût de
servir et perd ce moment là la première
étape ce mardi à ceux qui sont élus
demandent à la demande de l'ancien parti
c'est vraiment parti c'est le parti du
groupe
vous parlez de votre livre est une
réflexion sur le monde municipal le
cocon on ne va devenir une plateforme
pour avoir l'occasion d'aller en détail
dans plusieurs shows mais allons-y à gré
entre elles
est ce que vous serez par exemple
candidats plus de l'automobile par
rapport à madame plante qui est
candidate du vélo si je veux faire une
caricature
c'est ce qui est le problème c'est
qu'actuellement on essaie de braquer des
modes de transport la voiture va
demeurer
on a besoin en fait de parler de
mobilité on a besoin
moi j'ai moi je suis allé chercher une
expérience aussi une expertise dans les
quatre dernières années en matière de
mobilité
si on veut avoir des milieux de vie il
faut augmenter la densité mais il faut
assurer qu'il ya des transports
collectifs
on avait fait la phase 1 du rem ou deux
journées de la phase 2 on doit on en
avait un serbe il faut finir la ligne
bleue liot la rtm qui se cherche donc un
rôle à jouer au niveau 2 en termes de
concept mais la majorité comme très
concrètement mettant les noms mais j'ai
pas dis vous étiez pas le rêve les voies
pour les indices clés c'est ce que vous
allez venir
prenons l'exemple de bellechasse où les
commerçants étaient furieux allez vous
l'enlevez permettre les places de
stationnement ce genre d'affaires
deskjet vous avez fait votre tête là
dessus
la première chose qu'on doit faire parce
qu'à l'époque vous souvenez aref salem
avec le groupe de transport en avait on
s'était donné une politique du
stationnement puis c'est quelque chose
qui gravit piqué qui évoluent les
premières choses qu'on doit faire là
c'est que consultation ça veut dire
vraiment parler aux gens ça veut dire
d'aller voir les commerçants
si on veut que distribuer la richesse il
faut aussi la craie il faut que les
quartiers deviennent pas juste des
vareuses trio mais aussi des lieux de
destination
ok des places où la piétonnisation peut
se faire pendant une période il y en a
d'autres que ça peut se faire de façon
hybride comme saint denis par exemple
oui faut sécuriser le désastre
commercial
ça doit être commercial aussi donc je
vais aller à la rencontre des
commerçants
j'ai parlé à plusieurs d'entre eux déjà
puis on va voir ce qu'on peut faire mais
mail à bord du man la dernière de tout
dernièrement enregistrements pour le
rêve vous avez vu on disait que les
chiffres et gino les deux autres le
monsieur gendron lequel est écrit le
dernier la qui avait dit avait peut-être
qu'on aurait dû faire autrement
puis à l'intérieur de soi quand on
regarde en effet on n'est pas sûr pour
les chiffres je parle pas je parle pas
de reporter mais je vous dis que ça me
tente d'être factuel des audiences
braqué un contre l'autre on peut tu
travailler ensemble votre ex diagonale
on veut voir à l'écran
il ressort en titi à l'aller une grosse
dans le parcours la voyez la ligue le
voyez vous la ligue rose était droite
était moins défini et vous vous c'est un
serpentin droit mais ça va au même
endroit pourquoi vous avez tarim madame
plante si vous arrivez quatre ans après
avec quelque chose qui ressemble
beaucoup à la ligne rouge je pense qu'il
ya une distinction entre un tracé et
puis un concept qui est réalisable je
pense que oui la mobilité c'est
important oui écouter gérer ses 45 ans
est un ardent le mont a mis le feu le
mar ayan dessus retourne dans sa tombe à
chaque fois qu'on parle de métro peel
montréal nord vous avez le rem qui vote
qui va passer par là il faut assurer
qu'on puisse créer de la mobilité là où
il ya de la densité
alors que dans certains corps ça peut
sembler les mêmes mais ce que je propose
c'est pas intéressé s'est dit que là où
il ya des manques il y en a on a besoin
de mobilité mais permet de le faire oui
mais parmi votre réflexion depuis 4h que
vous a dit peut-être que j'ai été un peu
trop expéditif en riant à propos de
certains projets de transports
collectifs et 6 ha dont montréal a
besoin c'est des projets de transports
collectifs
vous savez on a besoin de transports
collectifs on a besoin de projets moi
même à l'époque que je vais proposer
qu'on qu'on fasse la ligne bleue qu'on
la fénice sur rails
et puis la ddt et d'autres personnes qui
ont ri puis était dans l'opposition moi
je pense que maintenant on va arrêter de
rire
on doit rendre des services à la
population mais ce qui est plus
important c'est qu'il faut sortir de
cette crise de cette pandémie pour créer
de l'espoir
j'ai dans un coin à montréal là où on a
promis beaucoup puis on a livré peu on
est en train de remettre en cause même
le rem dans certains qu on a
l'impression qu'on jette le bébé avec
l'eau du bain
ce que j'aimerais c'est qu'on puisse
faire en sorte que les gens de l'est de
montréal plus arrêter de se sentir comme
des parents pobi paye des taxes aux
autres ici et on va leur donner les
outils plus les moyens pour réaliser les
jo le rêve de l'ess moi j'ai fait une
entrevue la semaine dernière avec
monsieur arbaud quitte à la caisse que
dit la forêt était de nous dire que
c'est frayant un passage aérien ça peut
être possible parce que sur le terrain
c'est trop compliqué êtes vous favorable
à un segment aérien pour le rennes de
l'ess mais moi je pense que si c'est
faisable qui nous prouve que c'est la
chose à faire on doit le faire
maintenant j'ai deux favoris mais je
suis favorable à ce projet là comme j'ai
été favorable au premier projet psy un
deuxième projet parce qu'on a rien dit
de premier maintenant ça se fera pas en
vase clos cette affaire là on est
capables de se parler parce que dans un
concept de développement de transports
collectifs
les deux choses sont importants le
concept de développement bien concept de
financements alors dans les deux corps
il faut s'assurer qu'on attache les fils
et que au lieu d'avoir l'impression
qu'on fait partie de la salle d'attentes
qu'on n'ait pas écouté ou qu'on est on
n'a pas les coudées franches
ça prend des bonnes personnes aux bonnes
places et il faut respecter aussi
l'indépendance financière
notre processus financiers de raucourt
du côté de la caisse là jusqu'à un
instrument politique
le problème c'est qu'on a policiers
beaucoup trop la question des transports
collectifs bon de la caisse en tout cas
de l'argent pour le faire pas le fait en
a qui trouvent qu'elle a trop de pouvoir
c'est pas votre avis moi je pense qu'on
est capable de travailler ensemble parce
qu'on le démontrer dans la phase avec le
gouvernement de monsieur couillard de
monsieur trudeau et avec
l'administration maria avant de vous
laisser aller monsieur coderre je pense
quand j'ai posé la question aujourd'hui
là j'ai pas entendu aux autres entrevues
mais j'imagine sur le support est pas le
décevoir
êtes vous favorable à ce que québec
d'abord mettre de l'argent public pour
un nouveau stade donbass un hippie
moi je suis favorable pour que le
premier ministre est qu'il le dit presse
avoir des tous les choses entre les
mains pour pouvoir prendre une décision
éclairée
quand on est en sortie de crise et que
vous avez des gens d'affaires qui
veulent proposer un projet structurant
qui pourrait amener un rayonnement
montréal il faut le regarder mais pas
n'importe quel prix alors qu'attendez
vous les regardez mon amour rien
montréal et des prix avec des pluies
avaient été présentement mais il n'y a
pas d'argent qu'on demande pour le stade
donc mais la demande est là pour des des
actions et routiers si tout le monde est
d'accord
vous allez avoir de toute façon à
proposer des services qui vont avec
connexes au clip ça se fait parce que
quand on parle d'un stade quand on
pardonner pour lequel projets
structurants il va avoir des logements
des choses là dedans donc vous y croyez
ce projet de votants c'est que même un
temps partiel mais pas n'importe quel
prix ce qui est important parce que
regarder si on veut projet est petit on
veut s'assurer que les choses se fassent
adéquatement
on va commencer par attendre les faits
le faisons ça pour la même chose pour
une grande entreprise qui venait
s'installer à montréal même affaire
alors on va on va attendre
on va laisser le premier ministre le
bourg prend ses décisions tout le monde
est pour et d'accord avec le projet mais
disent pas de l'argent public
ou comment on va le faire maintenant il
ya plusieurs façons de trouver du
financement qui valait peut-être pas de
l'argent public ni trop froides à des
boîtes en est libre pour l'instant
réglons la pandémie denis coderre on
n'attendait pas aussi longtemps pour
refaire une entrevue avec un pack va
partir déjà partie d'une certaine façon
je veux deux choses
j'allais présenter une équipe bat au fur
et à mesure c'est quand même c'est moi
mais non même pas mais on va le faire
individuellement il ya déjà des gens qui
m'ont approché pour se présenter j'en ai
approché également demain je veux jouer
attendre avec beaucoup d'impatience le
résultat du caucus des membres danse à
montréal le but c'est de développer un
consensus c'est d'être pragmatique c'est
de donner à manger à tous les
montréalais
bien je pense quand l'opportunité denis
coderre merci beaucoup nous avons parlé
de voir